I find it interesting to think about
it's not your fault but it is your
responsibility don't get me wrong I
think that right now the vast majority
of people need to take more
responsibility I can see elements in my
life though of times when I've blamed
myself for things which I'm in no way
even remotely associated with well
here's two examples of what you're
talking about so if you're working for
me and you don't show up on time I need
to say something to you and I need to
take ownership of the fact that I
haven't made it clear that hey you need
to show up on time and hey you need to
be more professional and maybe if I do
and I talk to you and we discuss why
it's important and you say oh yeah I
really didn't think about that and you
change your ways or maybe you're late
again or you continue to act on
professionally and then I'm gonna get
rid of it that can happen and I have to
take ownership of the fact that you are
actually not capable of doing this job
that I've asked you same thing can
happen in a relationship right if you're
in a relationship with someone you're
bickering about you came home late from
work and all you do is well I've been
working all day you should respect the
fact that I've been working on it like
that's actually on you and you can make
adjustments to that there's plenty of
times where taking ownership means
actually solving the problem